my name is Bob Edwards some with in GP
energy have a management a large global
private equity fund my realization here
at Davos on the environment is that it
will be a long time before a tangible
concrete climate treaty even a global
agreement is reached in the meantime
it's becoming apparent and I think you
see any agenda of conference certainly
in the bus okaya Paul's meditation is
going to be critical the better I
fluently with that water is surpassing
the debate now about if wind and solar
it's a matter now of figuring out what
we're going to do in the next 20 or 30
years of the impact of climate change
population growth organization becomes
apparent and so that's the interesting
sessions how do we get how to recede 9.2
million people in how to wait but
release the water that's necessary to
your Lord to irrigate the crops in
America feet absolutely baby thank you